well somebody is lying about what
happened during the events that led up
to the evacuation of the the animals
from afghanistan and i think it's become
increasingly clear that the prime
minister's story is not credible he has
not told the truth the emails that were
released by the foreign affairs
committee yesterday show very clearly
that officials were instructed to on the
prime minister's authority to take
action to commission a plane
and this is really important because
while the afghanistan crisis unfolded
the prime minister was on a beach the
foreign secretary was on a beach and
thousands of people who assisted us
through two decades in afghanistan have
been left behind and yet the prime
minister has lied about what he did
and the actions that he took during that
time that is a a really serious thing
for the people of this country but it's
also incredibly damaging to britain's
reputation in the world i think it's
becoming increasingly clear that you
cannot believe a word that our prime
minister says and i say that with real
sadness having served in parliament for
12 years under successive prime
ministers none of them from my own party
but all of whom treated the public with
a level of respect that this prime
minister simply will not show